well as many of you know the results of
the recent election were as follows
Hillary Clinton the Democratic candidate
won a landslide victory with 52% of the
overall vote Jill Stein the green
candidate came a distant second with 19
percent Donald J Trump the Republican
candidate was caught on her heels with
14 percent and the remainder of the
votes were shared between abstainers and
Gary Johnson the libertarian candidate
now what parallel universe do you
suppose I live in well I don't live in a
parallel universe I live in the world
and that is how the world voted so let
me take you back and explain what I mean
by that in June this year I launched
something called the global vote and the
global vote does exactly what it says on
the tin for the first time in history it
lets anybody anywhere in the world vote
in the election of other people's
countries now why would you do that
what's the point well let me show you
what it looks like you go to a website
rather a beautiful website and then you
select an election here's a bunch that
we've already covered we do about one a
month or thereabout so you can see
Bulgaria United States of America
secretary-general of the United Nations
the brexit referendum at the end there
you select the election that you're
interested in and you pick the
candidates these are the candidates from
the recent presidential election in the
tiny island nation of south for me and
príncipe one hundred ninety nine
thousand inhabitants of the coast of
West Africa and then you can look at the
brief summary of each of those
candidates which I dearly hope is very
neutral very informative and very
think when you found the one you like
you vote these were the candidates in
the recent Icelandic presidential
election and that's the way it goes so
why on earth would you want to vote in
another country's election well the
reason that you wouldn't want to do it
let me reassure you is in order to
interfere in the democratic processes of
another country that's not the purpose
at all in fact you can't because usually
what I do is I release the results after
the electorate in each individual
country has already voted so there's no
way that we could interfere in that
process but more importantly I'm not
particularly interested in the domestic
issues of individual countries that's
not what we're voting on so what Donald
J Trump or Hillary Clinton proposed to
do for the Americans is frankly none of
our business that's something that only
the Americans can vote on now in the
global vote you're only considering one
aspect of it which is one of those
leaders going to do for the rest of us
and that's so very important because we
live as no doubt you're sick of hearing
people tell you in a globalised
hyper-connected massively interdependent
world where the political decisions of
people in other countries can and will
have an impact on our life no matter who
we are no matter where we live like the
wings of the butterfly beating on one
side of the Pacific that can apparently
create a hurricane on the other side so
it is with the world that we live in
today
and the world of politics there is no
longer a dividing line between domestic
and international affairs any country no
matter how small even if it's south for
me and príncipe could produce the next
Nelson Mandela or the next Stalin they
could pollute the atmosphere in the
oceans which belong to all of us well
they could be responsible and they could
help all of us and yet the system is so
strange because the system hasn't caught
up with this globalized reality only a
small number of people are allowed to
vote for those leaders even though their
impact is gigantic and almost universal
what
number was it 140 million Americans
voted for the next president of the
United States and yet as all of us knows
in a few weeks time somebody is going to
hand over the nuclear launch code to
Donald J Trump now if that isn't having
a potential impact on all of us I don't
know what is similarly the election for
the referendum on the the brexit vote a
small number of millions of British
people voted on that but the outcome of
the vote whichever way it went would
have had a significant impact on the
lives of tens hundreds of millions of
people around the world and yet only a
tiny number could vote what kind of
democracy is that huge decisions that
affect all of us being decided by
relatively very small numbers of people
and I don't know about you but I don't
think that sounds very democratic so I'm
trying to clear it up but as I say we
don't ask about domestic questions in
fact I only ever asked two questions of
all of the candidates I send them the
same two questions every single time I
say one if you get elected what are you
going to do for the rest of us for the
remainder of the seven billion who live
on this planet second question what is
your vision for your country's future in
the world what role do you see it
playing every candidate I send them
those questions they don't all answer
don't get me wrong I reckon if you're
standing to become the next president of
the United States you're probably pretty
tied up most of the time so I'm not
altogether surprised that they don't all
answer but many do more every time and
some of them do much more than answer
some of them answer in the most
enthusiastic and most exciting way you
could imagine I just want to say a word
here for Savior chiumbo who is one of
the candidates in the recent Zambian
presidential election his answers to
those two questions were basically an 18
page dissertation on his view of
Zambia's potential role in the world and
in the international community I posted
it on the website so anybody could read
it now Xavier won the global vote but he
didn't win the Zambian election so I
find myself wondering what am I going to
do with this extraordinary group of
people I've got some wonderful people
here who won the global vote we always
it wrong by the way the one that we
elect is never the person who's elected
by the domestic electorate but maybe
partly because we always seem to go for
the woman but I think it may also be a
sign that the domestic electorate is
still thinking very nationally they're
still thinking very inwardly they're
still asking themselves what's in it for
me instead of what they should be asking
today which is what's in it for we but
there you go
so suggestions please not right now but
send me an email if you've got an idea
about what we can do with this amazing
team of glorious losers we've got
Saviour to chamber who I mentioned
before we've got Hassler Thomas de
théâtre who was the runner-up in the
Icelandic presidential election many of
you may have seen her amazing talk at
Ted women just a few weeks ago where she
spoke about the need for more women to
get into politics
we've got Maria das Mavis from South AMA
and príncipe we've got in a reclaim
tonight don't know if she's available
we've got Jill Stein and we covered also
the election for the next Secretary
General of the United Nations and we've
got the ex prime minister of New Zealand
who would be a wonderful member of the
team so I think maybe those people the
glorious losers Club could travel around
the world wherever there's an election
and remind people of the necessity in
our modern age of thinking a little bit
outwards and thinking of the
international consequences so what comes
next to the global vote well obviously
the Donald and Hillary show is a bit of
a difficult one to follow but there are
some other really important elections
coming up in fact they seem to be
multiplying there's something going on
I'm sure you've noticed in the world and
the next row of elections are all
critically important in just a few days
time we've got the re-run of the
Austrian presidential election with the
prospect of Norbert Hoffa becoming what
is commonly described as the first
far-right head of state in Europe since
the Second World War
next year we've got Germany we've got
France
we've got presidential elections in Iran
and a dozen others it doesn't get less
important it gets more and more
important
clearly the global vote is not a
standalone project it's not just there
on its own it had some background it's
part of a project which I launched back
in 2014 which I call the good country
the idea of a good country is basically
very simple it's my simple diagnosis of
what's wrong with the world and how we
can fix it what's wrong with the world
I've already hinted that basically we
face an enormous and growing number of
gigantic existential global challenges
climate change human rights abuses mass
migration terrorism economic chaos
weapons proliferation all of these
problems which threaten to wipe us out
are by their very nature globalized
problems no individual country has the
capability of tackling them on its own
and so very obviously we have to
cooperate and we have to collaborate as
nations if we're going to solve these
problems it's so obvious and yet we
don't we don't do it nearly often enough
most of the time countries still persist
in behaving as if they were warring
selfish tribes battling against each
other much as they have done since the
nation state with invented hundreds of
years ago and this has got to change
this is not a change in political
systems or a change in ideology this is
a change in culture we all of us have to
understand but thinking in words is not
the solution to the world's problems we
have to learn how to cooperate and
collaborate a great deal more and
compete just a tiny bit less otherwise
things are going to carry on getting bad
and they're going to get much worse much
sooner than we anticipate this change
will only happen if we ordinary people
tell our politicians that things have
changed we have to tell them that the
culture has change we have to tell them
that they've got a new mandate the old
mandate was very simple and very single
if you're on a position of power or
authority you're responsible for your
own people and your own tiny slice of
territory and that's it and if in order
to do the best thing for your own people
you screw over everybody else on the
planet that's even better that's
considered to be a bit matchup
today I think everybody in a position of
power and responsibility has got a dual
mandate which says if you're in a
position of power and responsibility
you're responsible for your own people
and for every single man woman child and
animal on the planet you're responsible
for your own slice of territory and for
every single square mile of the Earth's
surface and the atmosphere above it and
if you don't like that responsibility
you should not be in power that for me
is the rule of the modern age and that's
the message that we've got to get across
to our politicians and show them that
that's the way things have done these
days otherwise we're all screwed I don't
have a problem actually with Donald
Trump's credo of America first it seems
to me that that's a pretty banal
statement of what politicians have
always done and probably should always
do of course they're elected to
represent the interests of their own
people but what I find so boring and so
old-fashioned
and so unimaginative about his take on
that is that America first means
everyone else last but making America
great again means making everybody else
small again and it's just not true in my
job as a policy advisor over the last 20
years or so I've seen so many hundreds
of examples of policies that harmonize
the international and the domestic needs
and they make better policy I'm not
asking nations to be altruistic or
self-sacrificing that would be
ridiculous no nation would ever do that
I'm asking them to wake up and
understand that we need a new form of
governments which is possible and which
harmonizes those two needs does good for
our own people and does good for
everybody else since the u.s. election
and since brexit it's become more and
more obvious to me but those old
distinctions of left wing and right wing
no longer make sense anymore
they really don't fit the pattern what
does seem to matter today is very simple
whether your view of the world is that
you take comfort from looking inwards
and backwards or whether like me you
find hope in looking forwards and
outwards that's the new politics that's
the new division that is splitting the
world right down the middle
now that may sound judgmental but it's
not meant to be I don't at all
misunderstand why so many people find
their comfort in looking inwards and
backwards when times are difficult when
you're short of money when you're
feeling insecure and vulnerable it's
almost a natural human tendency to turn
inwards to think of your own needs and
to discard everybody else's and perhaps
to start to imagine that the past was
somehow better than the present or the
future could ever be but I happen to
believe that that's a dead end
history shows us that it's a dead end
when people turn inwards and turn
backwards human progress becomes reverse
and things get worse for everybody very
quickly indeed if you're like me and you
believe in forwards and outwards and you
believe that the best thing about
humanity is its diversity and the best
thing about globalization is the way
that it stirs up that diversity that
cultural mixture to make something more
creative more exciting more productive
than has ever been before in human
history then my friends we've got a job
on our hands because the inwards and
backwards Brigade are uniting as never
before and that Creed of inwards and
backwards that fear that anxiety playing
on the simplest instincts is sweeping
across the world those of us who believe
as I believe in forwards and outwards we
have to get ourselves organized because
time is running out very very quickly
you